Speaker 1: Let's hear from some people in
the audience. If you'd like to chat with me,
you can go to David Pakman dot com slash
discord. We use the discord for calls,
and that is a great, great thing. Let's
start today with Felix from Maryland.
Speaker 2: Felix, you're
Speaker 1: on the air. What's going on?
Speaker 4: And not too much, are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, thank you.
Speaker 4: I wanted to ask you, excuse me, I'm
a little sick. Do you think that? This day,
we're in the middle of a political realignment.
Speaker 1: Well, tell me more, a
political realignment of what kind.
Speaker 4: You know, I don't know, I've I've just
kind of like been watching politics from afar for
a while and I feel like I just feel like a lot has
changed in like like since I really started paying
attention more back, like 2008 when Obama ran. And
I feel like a lot has changed, mainly from like
the culture war. And I felt like a lot of like
culture and social issues were making people who
are sort of apolitical or not really, you know,
super focused on politics. It would help them
come more to the left because a lot of people have
felt like we're turned off because the right was
more like a family values social conservative type
of party. Yeah, I feel like that's changed a lot.
You the right and the Republicans are like
now, like they've they've completely abandoned,
especially after Trump. They've abandoned the
whole like family, Judeo-Christian values,
esthetic and stuff. And now just weirdly see that
the cultural war started to like benefit them.
Speaker 2: Well. So let's see.
Speaker 1: You're absolutely right about some
of these particulars that you're noticing.
Speaker 2: I don't think it's
Speaker 1: a realignment in the
Speaker 2: sense of Republicans
Speaker 1: and Democrats are switching and
what it means to be in one party versus the
other. I don't think that that's changing.
I think the realignment that we're seeing
is that it started under Obama and it
exploded under Trump, and it's continuing now.
Republicans are no longer even pretending to
be about policy. They are, as you pointed out,
they're about cultural issues, they're about
owning the libs, they're about trying to win
elections by deciding which ballots do and don't
count. They're not really making substantive and
meaningful political cases to their voters,
saying, Here are the things we will do, and
here's why it will help you. They'll still vaguely
say the Democrats are crushing us with that,
or they're crushing us with taxes or whatever.
Speaker 2: But that's like,
that's not that doesn't
Speaker 1: count as policy
in my mind. You're not really substantively
proposing alternatives and solutions other
than we'll cut taxes and we'll pay down the debt,
Speaker 2: which they don't ever do. But I think
Speaker 1: that the realignment is that they used
to at least pretend to be about policy. They don't
even pretend to be about policy anymore, you know?
Speaker 4: Yeah, I think that's true to an extent.
Uh, but I definitely feel like they
used to pretend to be about policy and
like on the like cultural issues they
they used to be all about, like upholding,
you know, family values and stuff like
that. Like I was saying. Yeah, but
I feel like I feel like now I don't know. I just
feel like I've seen like more a little bit more
like diversity in thinking of some people who
would like vote right wing. And the fact that,
like a lot of them seem to even like support
drug legalization, a lot of them have kind
of like come to terms with letting, you know,
allowing same sex marriage and things like that,
right? No, that's a good point. I'm curious,
like where where this is going, because even like
in a few years from now, like what? What are
they what? What are what's the party going
to look like and what is their vote? What are
their base and their voters going to look like?
If this continues, I feel like they could win
over a lot of people on some of those issues.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, what you're pointing to
is that there were a bunch of people who before
Trump were never politically
Speaker 2: engaged or
Speaker 1: motivated at all. And
what Trump was able to do was
find people who never paid attention to
Speaker 2: politics and basically say,
Speaker 1: Here are your values and vote for me
and I'm a Republican. So Trump did. To his credit,
bring in people who believe themselves to be,
for example, against military interventions
around the world because Trump claimed to be
against that. But Trump's not really against
that. It was just a way that he was able
to criticize George W. Bush. You're right
that they don't seem to be homophobic. Some
of these folks, at least not outwardly so,
because Donald Trump did not make that a big
part of his campaign. I think you're absolutely
Speaker 2: right, but I think the
Speaker 1: bigger question is,
do those people really stay engaged in politics
after Trump is gone? And we don't know the answer
to that yet. They may or they may bail.
Speaker 4: OK. Yeah, well, it's just
been really interesting, it's just all the
time, I say these days, if I could go back
in time and tell myself like this, be the
environment would look like years from now,
I would be shocked. Yes, it would is. It
would be appreciated. If you have a good day.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Have a good one. All
right. There we go. There is. There is Felix.